when a crisis has occurred at the end of
the day you simply cannot go back and
repair whatever happened the oil is out
of the well the situation has been
reported and people extrapolate and base
their evaluation of you by how you
handle it going forward are you someone
who is credible are you trustworthy and
once you come to the decision will come
to the realization that the story is out
there is going to be moving you're
always better off to put it out on your
own terms
get the credibility for it get the
benefit of the doubt in terms of
actually providing the whole story out
there and so the first and most
important of the ten commandments the
one that really sort of sets your course
going forward is the capacity to go out
there and put it out on your own terms
fully disclose it
who is the most important audience that
you are speaking to that you're
disclosing information to this
ultimately those people are the ones who
are going to make a decision up or down
and whether you're credible and whether
ultimately you can be trusted going
forward so you need to identify exactly
who it is now typically there's a series
of Co centric circles right there's a
bull's-eye of the most important
audience or most important audiences and
it expands outward it doesn't mean you
have to be mutually exclusive you could
talk to all the audiences but most
importantly you need to make sure you
were talking to your core audience and
build out from there what you certainly
do not want to do when the flames are
out there is take a big gallon of
gasoline and throw it on right that
proverbial don't bring the backhoe in
when you find yourself in the hole and
keep on digging so you want to take a
step back and consider every single
action that you take every single step
that you take every statement you make
every comment that you make is it done
in a way that is gonna allow you to be
credible and trustworthy or are you
doing the stuff that may unintentionally
actually contribute to the particular
problem that you're dealing with
the only way you can kill bad facts are
correct bad facts is with good facts and
so there is a burden of proof so to
speak on the person who is in the crisis
you simply can't say that what's been
reported is not true or it's only half
true or that there's another side of the
story to actually get your story out
there to actually convey and communicate
effectively in an incredible way you
either have to be able to provide people
the specific facts because they're the
core facts that they're looking at in a
particular situation or you need to be
able to identify a process that you're
gonna pursue to be able to get to those
but at the end of the day you can't get
the small details wrong right there's
been so many situations where someone
has been in a crisis and they've
actually tried to do everything right
they've disclosed they've disclosed to
the core audience that they wanted to
talk to but they get a fat crop
they could have factory drive I have
something off and suddenly that
particular thing that they missed that
particular detail that they got wrong
looms much bigger because people are
gonna have a very cynical and skeptical
perspective of them and if that detail
is wrong they're gonna think for some
reason you were trying to hide it or for
some reason you're not trying to
communicate it in a truthful way so you
have to make sure that when you're gonna
put the information out you've thought
through the questions that you're gonna
get and you either answer them with a
level of detail and specificity that
your core audience expects or provide a
process that you will pursue pursue to
ultimately get there
hold your head high means it cannot be
embarrassed about the situation so
embarrassed that you're not willing to
put out the entire story there's the The
Full Monty we call it right which is you
have to put everything out there and you
want to do it and one fell swoop because
your ability actually moved beyond the
crisis to control it to limit the
ultimate damage you know is dependent on
your willingness and capacity to go out
there and make sure you put it all out
there and one fell swoop and do it and
not keep different pieces back and not
do it in a way where the information
ends up dribbling out over the long-term
go ahead held high pop the balloon get
it out there and you're done with it
he's traded about what you know be
straight about what you don't know and
in situations where you don't have
information make sure you put in place
some type of a credible process so that
your audience's believe you're
ultimately trying to get that
information typically the way this will
manifest itself is a company an
organization is facing some kind of a
challenge they simply don't know what
the answers are can't get their hands
around all the information so they bring
in an outside expert to conduct a review
that is ultimately made public or a view
that makes recommendations which are
ultimately adopted but you need to make
sure that you're being very clear with
your audiences this is what we do know
there's some stuff we don't know but
we're actually giving you guys a process
of it and we're conveying what that
process is gonna be and then we're
meeting the expectations that we are
establishing by putting this process out
there so that those audiences do have
faith that you're trying to get the
answers that they want to hear
in crises there is a natural human
tendency to not communicate as
forcefully and as effectively as you
need to when in fact in a crisis you
want to err on the side of almost over
communicating to begin with there is so
much noise and information out there
that an able to break through with your
message to resonate with your core
audience to give the information that
people are looking for you need to do it
loudly you need to do it consistently
you do it repetitively and you need to
do it in a way that it ultimately does
resonate with them so that they're
hearing it so when you're in a crisis
that's not good enough just to put out
the information sometimes it's not gonna
have just to put out the information
once you have to do it any number of
times and you have to be able to
determine is your core audience hearing
this right because you could be fully
disclosed you could be doing everything
right but if they don't hear it you're
not actually accomplishing what your
strategy is designed to accomplish
typically in a crisis situation there
are multiple entities involved multiple
people who may face exposure or be or be
part of the crisis and in those steps of
a situation you have to look around and
figure out if there's a way they get
yourself in on stage and off stage as
quickly as possible now that's part and
parcel of making sure you put the
information out there that you're taking
responsibility that you're doing a heavy
held high that you're putting all the
details all of those things come
together but it can be extremely
beneficial to be the first guy on there
and then the first guy off because
typically the others who are left on
stage end up having a much longer
protracted challenge as opposed to get
yourself out of the crisis and moving on
to your next stage in a crisis there
will be someone who is a competitor
someone who's an opponent someone who
may not necessarily have clean hands in
this entire situation and in fact may be
involved in putting information out may
be involved in trying to inflict damage
and harm on you and getting that
information out will certainly impact
how external audiences view you and in
fact interpret that information and so
if there is someone out there trying to
fan the flames it's ultimately important
for other folks to know that and be
aware of it and it's incumbent upon you
because no one else is gonna do it it's
incumbent upon you to make sure that you
point that out and you do it forcefully
now to do that effectively you also have
to make sure that you've done the other
commandments you have to have the basis
for being able to say here's our
information we're holding ourselves
accountable
we're being responsible but by the way
there's another part of the story that
you should be aware of that I think will
reframe it or put it in a different type
of a context
if someone is an opponent of yours or if
someone that has unclean hands as an and
is involved in disseminating information
that is causing you problems and they
themselves make a misrepresentation a
good way to be able to turn the tables
put the issue back on them diminish the
amount of exposure that you have is to
specifically point out the
misrepresentation or misrepresentations
that they are making that helps you
establish your credibility and at the
same time it undermines their
credibility and allows you to create a
different narrative it alternative
narrative out there on the particular
crisis